le beurre c'est du beurre dit le slogan
mais tous les beurs ne se ressemblent
pas
celui de la famille grenier à weedon en
estrie est un véritable beurre fermier
la recette pendant mon père fier de mon
arrière grand parent ou si je faisais du
beurre maison jetons puisse entrer cette
l'offre comprend aujourd'hui pour faire
leur beurre de qualité
la famille grenier possède non seulement
une ferme laitière mais aussi une
fromagerie
tout part d'un auteur jusqu'à vos
assiettes mais frère s'occupe de la
firme azotés alimente les animaux en
conséquence pourrait chercher une belle
qualité de lait qui ont fait du bon
fromage mais à partir du lactosérum de
mes fromages mais moi j'ai crime ça
c'est à partir de là que je fais mon bac
ce beurre et particulier la crème est
extraite du petit lait le résidu de la
fabrication du fromage on met un peu
termine demain pour donner un goût
différent je récupère ma crème
je les mets dans ma barre à tabarre je
laisse pas rater 1 heure deux heures
ensuite de tout je soutiens mon petit
beurre jeu-là montbard ensuite je peux
commencer emballé selon la demande
d'amitié
la fromagerie ne produit que quelques
kilos par jour un véritable produit de
niche
[Musique]
les producteurs de beurre du spécialités
sont peu nombreux au québec sans être
artisanale la laiterie chagnon de
waterloo demeure une laiterie
indépendante elle fabrique du beurre de
spécialités à partir de lait qui
provient de fermes situées dans un rayon
de 30 km
en europe est une panoplie de beurre 2
disponible tandis qu'au québec on voit
qu'il ya un vide dans le marché on
aimerait remplir ce vide là on essaie de
ramener des beurs à valeur ajoutée un
peu comme en europe avec ces beurs de
spécialité la laiterie chagnon espère
conquérir le marché des grandes
épiceries
ici on produit le beurre à partir de la
crème
mais la recette est secrète
[Musique]
c'est surtout la fermentation qui peut
durer de 10 heures à quelques jours
dépendante du goût qu'on veut aller
chercher des ferments qu'on va mettre
dedans c'est la plus grande différence
ensuite le barattage aussi lors du
barrage et différentes techniques
peuvent changer le goût le pourcentage
de grosses le barattage consiste à
brasser la crème fermenter dans une
immense cuse pour en retirer l'eau et
extraire le beurre
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on a fabriqué aujourd'hui
lui c'est la salle est alors l'un des
gros grain de sel de bain avec les
autres quand même assez salée qui est il
goûte un peu un peu le fromage
au canada la réglementation prévoit que
le beurre doit contenir un minimum de
matière grasse alors les ibères
ordinaire on parle environs de 80 % greu
la différence entre grasse et surtout de
l'eau que dans les bars et de look est
extrait de plus et plus tu extrait l'eau
plus que ta doc du goût puis plus que
ces crèmes eux aussi et les producteurs
de beurre de spécialités se permettent
justement à taux de grade plus élevé
pour un goût plus relevé ouais bon le
barack pour avoir un pourcentage plus
haut autour de 81 3 84%
le beurre petits plaisirs pousse encore
un peu plus loin le plaisir du gras
d'abord été disposés d'humidité 90%
matières grasses on peut dire que je
d'abord une extension naturelle très bon
c'est le meilleur bar du québec
bah écoutez si l'adopter mais ce bon
goût de ba a aussi un prix on peut
dresser la double du crime
un autre homme d'abord le fait que oui
si plus de travail ça coût de la main
d'oeuvre sur place le beurre de la
fromagerie petits plaisirs coûte 4
dollars le pot de 300 grammes mais plus
cher ailleurs
merci beaucoup mais nani
[Musique]